one of the things i turn to when i'm
going through the hardest stuff
for me was self-soothing coping
mechanisms
how do i not feel this how do
i numb
how do i even like actually feel really
good that's the thing is like
who doesn't want to feel good like
feeling good
is feels good and feeling bad feels bad
and that's the big and like that's one
of the things
that i think you know jumping right into
it with no shame like i've been very
open about the fact that
you know toward the end of my illness i
developed a serious addiction to
to benzodiazepines to klonopin like i
was addicted to
anti-anxiety medication i was a good
old-fashioned pill head
i was like that is that is what i like
to call it because i don't
think that there needs to be a cute word
for it
because i don't think that we should
have shame
it's like if you think about it feeling
bad feels bad
feeling good feels good no one should be
ashamed about wanting to get out of pain
and what addiction is is like a desire
to get out of pain
and not having the tools to get out of
pain
and almost no one is given the proper
tools by their parents by their teachers
by the infrastructure of this country
and how we deal with mental health
to get out of pain and
i was really lucky i have an amazing
family i've been in therapy since i was
a kid
but somewhere along the path of my 20s
the way that my career swept me up
what i thought the expectations or what
i thought the expectations were
the way that people were looking at me
how i thought i had to perform
i just remember being so terrified of
the idea of disappointing people that
really for me at first i was like if i
can take these
drugs and they make me more like myself
isn't that a better thing
and then suddenly i realized i was
becoming less and less like myself
and suddenly it was like sobriety wasn't
a choice for me i was thrust
into it because i realized there was no
other way
that i was going to get back to the life
that i loved
and so in a way it was i'd love to think
it was this very zen
choice like you know what i think i'm
just going to have a dry january and
then it turned into a dry
but no it was like girl you gotta get it
together
and then but it turned out to be like
the greatest thing i ever did
like i'm almost three years out
i feel blessed that it's not something
that i i don't sit around every day
wishing i had like a high ball in my
hand or something i
i'm the greatest friends of my life have
come out of sobriety
that's not to say that life is perfect
every day but it's almost like i compare
it to like
in sobriety you're building this your
life is like this boat and you're
building this boat and it's not that
that issues don't come along but it's
like the boat's just kind of floating on
nice water
and then you're testing it and you're
seeing like does it actually work and
then like a huge wave comes along and
you're like
oh crap that didn't sink like we built a
pretty good boat
and i feel that way every time something
big
or scary or challenging comes along and
so right i'm like that boat's
that boat's still up that boat's still
bobbing the boat
perfect the wave i get it i so get it
did you have the voice of i know this is
not working
i'm sabotaging i'm not healthy
i'm not well but shh
i'm gonna fix it i'll get through the
day just shut up voices
i know what you're telling me i hear you
but i'm not listening
or was it denial and then the aha moment
which path 100 the first one you're
describing
like especially when i would lay down in
bed at night it would just be like
this is a disaster
and you know i regret in a certain way i
regret nothing the only things i regret
in life
are the moments that i've hurt people i
think
all the moments that i've hurt myself
were probably
pretty educational to be frank i
had times in my life where i think
you know maybe there's the on top of the
world
and then as you were
and whether it's subconscious or
conscious i guess that is the question
you burn it all down i have a really
interesting as i'm sure many of us do
relationship between the people pleaser
and me
and the rebel and me who are always
doing a dance with each other
and i think you may enjoy a little bit
of that
too i see you grooving to the same song
and so i think there was a part of me
that was like i don't know how to get
out of this phase of my life
i only know how to like pull the rip
cord
and i'm not saying anyone should feel
sorry for me for that it just is the
[Music]
truth
you